from a Chicago woman whose act of  kindness kept dozens of homeless people  out of the deadly cold  Candace pain put 20 hotel rooms on her  credit card as temperatures plummeted to  negative-20 adding to the misery a  propane tank fire forced some homeless  people to evacuate their camp Wow Wow  takes your breath away listen to that  act of kindness eventually pain and  other good Samaritans rented 60 hotel  rooms for about 80 people our Chicago  station WBBM spoke with her they left a  mode that people do want to help they  just maybe they didn't know how to start  you know I had a where to start to help  you know so I'm glad that and I was able  to be that vehicle and have a lot of  people jump on the vehicle with me a  beautiful vehicle she was paying says  she they want to find permanent homes  for some of those hotel guests Thank You  Candace Payne